this massive metropolis in the center of
China is at the heart of a virus
outbreak that has gone global
the first death from the new corona
virus outside of China cruise ship the
diamond princess remains quarantined in
Yokohama more than 71,000 people have
been infected around the world
in February Chinese officials and state
media touted a drop in the number of
daily new confirmed cases
but only hours later local authorities
released data showing a dramatic jump
partially due to a shift in the way new
cases were diagnosed and confirmed while
the authorities said the goal behind the
new criteria was to let more patients
receive better treatment this raised
concerns that the scale of the outbreak
has been larger than Chinese data had
earlier suggested we thought there was
better transparency coming out of China
but it doesn't appear to be in response
to the criticism Beijing said it has
been active and open toward cooperation
with international experts to
independently assess the scale of the
disease groups of scientists around the
world have been using mathematical
modeling and their estimate so far
exceed the officially reported numbers
the new virus was first detected in
December and by mid-january
the number of cases was just over 40 but
epidemiologists across the world thought
that something wasn't right when three
cases were confirmed outside of China
cases when there seemed to be relatively
small numbers Krystal Donnelly and her
colleagues at the Imperial College
London looked at the number of cases
outside China which they call exported
to calculate the scale of the outbreak
what kinds of big cities million people
in the metropolitan area and it has an
international airport and it's
interconnected so so their flights and
people traveling to lots of places they
used similar mathematical modelling
developed during the h1n1 influenza
outbreak in Mexico in 2009 you can look
at the number of cases that have been
exported and then there is a factor of
which you can use to then estimate the
number of cases that there were in the
source region
before the virus shut down the city the
International Airport operated flights
to dozens of major cities worldwide with
more than 3,000 passengers traveling
through the airport every day the
researchers also assumed that 10 days
likely passed between a person getting
infected and the disease being detected
but you can get an idea by looking at
the number of flights you know what's
the population size how many departures
international departures do you have on
a giving day the imperial college
researchers estimated that over 1700
people could have been infected in Wuhan
by mid January indicating a massive gap
between China's 41 confirmed cases
reported at that time and their
estimates other researchers did similar
calculations based on the exported
overseas cases and with several other
variables and came to similar results in
later reports scientists factored in new
data and their numbers were still much
bigger than Beijing's official tally of
confirmed cases these findings give a
rough picture and the margin of error
remains high in part because of other
factors like the fact that human to
human transmission was confirmed
overseas many people in China have been
critical of how Beijing has dealt with
the crisis and have been skeptical about
the official data Donnelly says that the
Imperial colleges analysis is not aimed
at criticising Beijing's efforts but
trying to look at what was going on and
what might be expected from the virus
she says that there are a myriad of
reasons why China's figures might not
reflect reality it's difficult for any
country the new disease starts in your
country there's a lot to be identified
to begin with so when it first starts
really don't know what is potential is
what makes it even harder to diagnose
the corona virus is that people infected
may show very mild symptoms like fever
and coughing there are also common in
other types of infections in an effort
to battle the virus Beijing has spent
about eight hundred million dollars
deployed thousands of medical staff and
built two field hospitals in days China
is doing many good things that slowing
the fight
and this has to be recognized well the
w-h-o repeatedly praised China other
public health experts have been more
critical it took the agency nearly two
weeks to get a go-ahead from Beijing to
send a group of experts to China to
conduct joint research with Chinese
scientists epidemiologists say they are
still learning about the new virus and
hope their research will help officials
in China to put effective measures in
place to tackle the outbreak
[Music]